important chapter in american history
the author is hank cox and the name of
the book is lincoln and the sioux
uprising of 1862. thank you sure
in riverrun red andrew ward chronicles
the battle at fort pillow during the
civil war
at this hour-long talk from the 2005
southern festival of books he details
the bigotry displayed during the battle
and the role played by nathan bedford
forrest the future founder of the ku
klux klan
greetings to you all and on behalf of
the southern festival of books i am your
host louis rickey
and i wish to welcome you to a
celebration of the written word
for which the session you were attending
this is not the tonya tucker session but
author andrew ward's session on the
river run red the fort pillow massacre
in the american civil war
this session will last approximately 50
minutes and we will allow time for
questions towards the end
and c-span book tv
is recording this session for
rebroadcast and there is a microphone to
your left if you can use that during the
question and answer session
i also wish to note that
mr wade mr ward excuse me will be
signing books in the colonnade after
this session
andrew ward was born in chicago in 1946
and educated at oberlin college in a
rhode island school of design and lives
with his wife in seattle
he is a former contributing editor at
the atlantic monthly
a commentator for national public
radio's all things considered
a columnist for the washington post and
screenwriter
he is the author of numerous books
including our bones are scattered his
account of the indian mutiny of 1857
that won the washington governor's award
most recently he published the
award-winning dark midnight when i rise
the story of the jubilee singers
which he adapted into a documentary for
wgbh televisions the american experience
his latest work river run red
was released on september the 26th just
a couple of weeks ago
by viking publishing and he's also he's
received several reviews since then
including publishers weekly
which said this massive narrative
painstakingly recounts the notorious
and much disputed massacre of the union
garrison at fort pillow tennessee
the author vividly builds his case
portraying a wide range of the actors in
the drama as well as the broader context
an outstanding addition to the civil war
literature that was by publishers weekly
and ken burns has said we usually
smother the often contradictory truths
of the civil war
with bloodless gallant myth obscuring
our chances to come to terms with our
defining moment andrew ward has cut
through this fog
bringing to light the painful facts of
the fort pillow massacre and the
terrifying fascinating figure behind it
nathan bedford forest please join me in
welcoming andrew ward
[Applause]
thank you thank you especially for
choosing me over tanya tucker this
morning
i want to thank the southern festival of
books and the national public library
for the invitation to speak here today
when katrina struck i thought the last
thing the south needs is another yankee
coming down
in the wake of this catastrophe to
peddle his book
but the devastation has humbled us all
and it is in an attitude of humility
that i come here not as a northerner but
as an american who shares in the grief
and shame of that catastrophe
to those who dismiss history is over and
done the hurricane has revealed in the
most painful conceivable way
that our history still lives among us
and most particularly the history of
slavery whose legacies were displayed
for all the world to see in the flood
waters of the mississippi and the tides
of the gulf
people who write about slavery are often
accused of being divisive of opening old
wounds as though we were not already
divided as though our wounds were not
already open
however weary we have become of
slavery's vestiges however eager we may
be to put it all behind us
we must remember that it will be more
than another century before we will have
been free of slavery in this country for
as long as we had it
anyone who writes about slavery does so
at his or her own peril for it was an
institution of such corrosiveness and
dimension that it has left its mark on
almost every aspect of american society
north and south
when i first began to study slavery a
decade ago i was afraid that this
growing obsession of mine would either
drive me crazy or at least
lead me into some literary backwater
from which i might never emerge
the first book i tried to write about it
was almost incoherent with rage and i
had to abandon it and find a story that
might extricate me from its pull
the result was dark midnight when i rise
the redemptive saga of the fisk jubilee
singers who took the anthems of their
bondage and used them to teach the world
about the culture of black america and
the educability of former slaves
why then would i turn next to the fort
pillow massacre by no means the most
decisive but certainly one of the most
divisive battles of the civil war
to begin with for reasons i should no
doubt take up with a therapist my
instincts keep leading me back to 19th
century massacres i have written two
books on the kanpur massacres in the
great indian mutiny of 1857 articles on
little bighorn and the zulu mayhem at
issan luana and now i have just emerged
from four years of writing and
researching river run red a documentary
account of the fort pillow massacre in
the american civil war
my fascination with massacres probably
stems from an irreligious fear of death
but then i also love a good mystery
and there is nothing in history more
mysterious and perplexing than massacres
in part because in no case not little
bighorn not the alamo not fort pillow
will everyone or even anyone agree on
exactly what happened
in any case as regularly as locusts say
return again and again to the epilogic
battlefield the scene of the crime in
this case the battered bluffs of fort
pillow
a union outpost on the tennessee banks
of the mississippi some 40 crow fly
miles from north of memphis
there on april 12 1864 the third
anniversary of the commencement of the
civil war
confederate cavalry under the audacious
command of nathan bedford forest overran
an outnumbered union garrison composed
in roughly equal portions of white
tennessee unionists and escaped slaves
turned artillerists
if the result of this collision of
southerners was the most notorious
atrocity of the civil war it owed a
measure of its infamy to the
machinations of northern radicals who
delectatiously broadcast the lurid
details of hundreds of soldiers
slaughtered after they surrendered of
wounded men murdered in hospital tents
of captives burned and buried alive of
black men lynched along the rebels
triumphant line of march
the south in turn responded to this
mixture of fact and fantasy much as it
had to the pre-war brick bats of the
abolitionists by hunkering down denying
everything and accusing the victims of
barbarity
wading through waters consecrated by
northern mythology bloodied by forest
cavalry and muddied by his defenders has
not been easy and my account is unlikely
to please anybody few come off
particularly well the black troops
proved to be neither the ciphers nor the
icons of either side's propaganda
they could not have been guilty of the
outrages against local civilians that
forest would accuse them of committing
as part of his defense
they had next to no horses were under
strict orders from their disciplinarian
commander to remain not just at fort
pillow but within their own works lest
they incense local whites or collide
with their white comrades
they fought bravely but i discovered
that some of the more iconic episodes
touted by the north of a black trooper
saving his regiment's colors by tucking
it under his shirt to bind his wounds of
his dead commander's widow ceremoniously
returning the bloodstained colors to his
men were apparently invented or staged
and far from inspiring thousands more
blacks to join the army the fort pillow
massacre and the union's official
refusal to retaliate actually slowed
western black recruitment to a trickle
though the fort pillow massacre was
preceded by a lynching of two slaves
none of forest black prisoners were
hanged along his line of march
a disproportion of black troops were
killed many after they'd throw down
their weapons but once the rebels rage
subsided
the black survivors fared far better
than their white comrades
white prisoners were a burden to the
confederacy but blacks were valued as
recovered property
the rebels fell victim to their own
antebellum
antebellum credulity however in the
course of returning their captives to
their masters or putting them to work on
rebel fortifications forest men eagerly
believed their black captives pleased
that they were quote good [ __ ]
unquote who'd been forced by the yankees
to fight against their masters so they
allowed them to venture out on small
errands whereupon many of them ran off
and returned to what was left of their
regiments
i found forest men to be not the poor
backwoods whites northerners represented
them to be most were men who owned or
stood to inherit substantial property
including slaves
this has made me wonder about the
oft-repeated claim that most southern
troops could not have been fighting to
defend slavery because they didn't own
any
most of forest men were too young to own
anything but in an economy whose quote
road to wealth unquote was lined with
slaves how many of them either stood to
inherit slaves or intended to buy a
couple just as soon as they possibly
could
the homegrown yankees of the 13th
tennessee cavalry usa were not very
different to someone who'd grown up
believing that the secessionist movement
was a monolithic force it was startling
to read about the number of forest men
who deserted and how early in the war
after the rebel fiasco at fort donelson
and the carnage at shiloh so many men of
the western confederacy abandoned the
rebel cause and even joined the union
army
as a result of a hasty and partisan
congressional investigation and an
equally partisan defense by forrest and
his officers two conflicting orthodoxies
have arisen around fort pillow
the north depicted the carnage's
premeditated slaughter for which it held
forest directly responsible southern
partisans accepted forrest's own defense
as holy writ
contending that the carnage to the
extent there was any was the result of
incompetence on the part of the
garrison's officers and drunken fool
hardiness on the part of its enlisted
men
this question of whether the affair at
fort pillow was a massacre has gotten
entangled with a question of whether
forrest intended a massacre but i think
these are separate questions after four
years of sifting through evidence i find
that like most human affairs it was a
muddle
a fair fight up to a point followed by a
mutation into murder with plenty of
blame to go around
forest field commanders at fort pillow
especially chalmers bell and mcculloch
share much of the blame for the anarchy
that ensued after the fort was overrun
two weeks after the massacre the radical
republican joint subcommittee on the
conduct of the war traveled west to
interview the survivors of the battle
many of whom lay wounded in hospitals
and cairo mound city memphis and fort
pillow itself
the testimony the subcommittee elicited
was certainly flawed as all testimony is
but after a careful examination of
literally hundreds of pension military
medical and ration commutation records
as well as letters diaries civilian
accounts and several visits to the
battlefield itself i found that the
survivor's testimony held up a far
better than its confederate counterpart
underlying a lot of the attacks on the
union testimony were traditions peculiar
to a slave society which marginalized
poor whites and prohibited slaves from
testifying against whites this tradition
induced a reflexive disinclination to
believe black testimony
forrest himself set the tone for his
defenders shortly after the wizards
surrendered a reporter asked him if the
public was to believe the subcommittee's
report
yes forrest neared if we are to believe
anything a negro says
forest defenders attack the survivor's
testimony is both too contradictory and
too well coordinated which is itself a
contradiction but never mind for whether
it is one or the other or both the
question remains compared to what
southern testimony came entirely from
officers determined to defend themselves
against northern charges and richmond's
disdain
it is their testimony far more than the
testimony of enlisted union men that
smacks of towing an official line
as for the testimony of southern
enlisted men two accounts not written
for public consumption testify to the
slaughter of black troops after they
throw down their weapons this may
explain why forrest did not collect his
own enlisted men's eyewitness testimony
despite a request from jefferson davis
himself and why he tried and ultimately
failed to elicit from one of his
prisoners a blanket endorsement of his
version of events
forest partisans attacked the testimony
on a host of grounds to deprecate the
garrison's defiance they claimed that
the federals fought on because they were
inebriated which they may well have been
but i found ample evidence that by the
time they overran the fort forest men
had also drunken themselves silly after
coming upon the yankees store of spirits
the general's defenders refuted claims
that some victims were bayoneted by
pointing out that forest cavalry did not
carry bayonets when in the same breath
and to prove that the victims never
surrendered at all they point out that
forest men picked up hundreds of garris
of the garrison's weapons along the
riverside many of which were outfitted
with bayonets that forest men would have
been free to employ
they say that no women or children could
have been killed because they had all
been ferried across the river before the
battle began
when in fact forest himself whose men
never crossed the river list women and
children among his prisoners captured at
fort pillow
they say that he did not violate the
truce by moving his men forward when one
of his own officers bragged that he and
his men crept up to the very rim of the
entrenchment while the white flag flew
there is a baby with a bathwater
character to a lot of the confederates
arguments for instance as part of a
blanket indictment of union testimony
they dismissed one soldier's account of
forest riding over the victims because
he described the towering general as
quote a little bit of a man
when obviously the soldier had merely
confused him with forest diminutive
field commander james ronald chalmers
who wore his whiskers just like forest
and was referred to by his men as little
one
forest admirers asked why if there was a
massacre the north never retaliated
when in fact lincoln issued warrants for
the arrest of forrest and his officers
but at last faced with what he called a
choice of evils decided that he could
not in good conscience execute random
rebel prisoners for forest crimes the
battle soon got lost in the horrible
generality of the war and for lincoln
the best retaliation was defeating the
south
i don't argue that all of the points
raised by forest officers were invalid
nor that every denial of a massacre was
dishonest on their part in some cases it
was a result of their not being present
at the time some of the atrocities
occurred
but few of their briefs stand up to
scrutiny for instance as a newly elected
mississippi congressman james ronald
chalmers forest field commander at fort
pillow
asked his colleagues how anyone could
believe in the blood guiltiness of a man
of his are addition temperance and
manifest decency
but i found that soon after the war
chalmers had demonstrated a continuing
capacity for such mayhem
by leading a band of confederate
veterans in a massacre of some 40 black
civilians who had peaceably assembled in
support of their sheriff
over and over again during my research i
was struck by the simultaneous intimacy
and alienation of slavery
i found several black troops and their
wives who'd been bought and sold by
forest during his slave trading days and
two cases in which black artillerists
encountered their rebel masters on the
battlefield forrest himself apparently
rescued a slave from death because he
recognized him as the table servant of
an old friend and colleague from his
slave trading days
in one especially poignant encounter a
slave who rode with forest escort as a
servant found his own nephew's body
lying among the union dead
one of the contradictions that the fort
pillow story forced me to embrace was
the character of nathan bedford forest
himself
he was a military genius a natural-born
dog of war perhaps the greatest cavalry
commander of all time
he was shrewd physically imposing an
almost peter naturally brave rioting
into the thick of battles other
commanders were content to observe from
a distance
but for a civilian resume is one of the
most dismal in the annals of the civil
war slave catcher and slave trader
before the war
co-founder of the ku klux klan and
pioneering convict labor contractor
after the war
after a string of post-war reverses he
seemed to approach
a measure of contrition for all this as
he wasted away apparently from diabetes
he spoke appeasingly to black assemblies
and meditated on the 51st psalm deliver
me from blood guiltiness o god thou god
of my salvation
but forest champions were less contrite
and tried to swallow the indigestible
lump of his slave trading by insisting
that he was a uniquely humane speculator
who refused to separate slave families
or sell them to cruel slave holders and
that he even permitted his slaves to go
out into the city and choose their own
masters
certainly a strain of humanitarianism
and a slave trader would have made
forest unique
but this deprecation of forests
wholehearted and supremely profitable
involvement in the very nexus of slavery
seems to me symptomatic of our
fundamental inability to acknowledge the
scale and impact of the crime of slavery
the claim that he did not separate
slaves is feeble in several respects
first it's not true
an otherwise admiring judge j.p young
recalled his quote childish indignation
unquote when forrest came by his parents
house and took away his nursemaid
emmeline a mother of two
according to a former slave named louis
hughes whose illegally enslaved wife and
family were sold in forest yard he
separated his family
thomas hooper future corporal in the six
united states colored heavy artillery
would have an even more fateful
rendezvous with forest at fort pillow
but as a boy he was bought with his
mother by forest who then sold him away
from her and just the other day
i came upon a reminiscence by a former
slave named priscilla parker who
remembered forest as the biggest slave
trader in tennessee
he dawn made lots of money by an and
selling she recalled and she should know
separated from her mother she her sister
and three brothers were bought by forest
and transported to his memphis slave pen
forrest promptly sold her sister to a
new orleans trader a brother to a man in
covington
another to a man in lebanon and a third
to another louisianan parker herself was
sold to a man from paducah and recalled
forrest was quote right well pleased by
her sale and quote say he done made 300
on me unquote
finally the meaning of family enslaved
society renders this most far-fetched of
forest's mercy's moot the peculiar
institution did all in its power to
destroy slaves parental authority and
filial devotion
slaveholders took it upon themselves to
name discipline feed house employ pair
off and otherwise determine the fates of
their slaves children
children were often raised not by their
mothers but by elderly slaves unfit for
field work and in any case sales and the
high mortality among slaves turned many
slave children into orphans
the result was that the wider slave
community and in some cases even the
slaveholders family itself became the
slaves only family so that any
separation from one's kith was as
profoundly damaging as from one's kin
as for forests allowing some trusted
slaves to go out into the city to seek
their own masters forest trade consisted
largely of selling upper south slaves to
buyers in the deep south where
conditions were so harsh that many
slaves regarded their exportation down
river is a death sentence
they also believe that the kindliest
masters did not attend auctions
it's therefore little wonder that slaves
would have applied defied masters for
themselves in any case this ostensible
nicety maybe not a measure of forest
kindness so much as further evidence the
slaves were so terrified of forrest and
his brothers that even when given an
opportunity they would not risk the
consequences of trying to run away
even forest friends admitted that his
slaves feared him quote exceedingly
unquote
i knowed mr forrest before the war
declared a contraband from columbus
kentucky i knowed him as well as i
knowed master jim he was hard on negros
before the war
another surprise that awaited me as i
embarked on my research was the extent
of the corruption that attended union
occupation along the mississippi just
about every district commander was
guilty of it i have rarely encountered a
worse set of inebriates crooks letters
incompetence cowards and assorted
detrimentals than the union officers
sherman left to mine the store as he set
off for his meridian campaign
in that scoundrel time even mrs lionel
booth the widow of the artillerist
heroic commander at fort pillow would
serve time for bribery
i have not sought to judge those who
were caught up in slavery and war as i
have experienced neither
it is one thing to live in the 21st
century and look back at slavery's
imperfect end it is another to be born
into a slave society as slave or master
or to wage war at its most grueling and
horrific
i cannot say how righteous i would have
been had i been entangled from birth in
the contracting tentacles of the
peculiar institution but i imagine that
even forest 21st century admirers would
recoil from the horrors to which
centuries of bondage and bloodshed had
ignored him
from the massacres i have studied i've
learned that even when there's no
prospect of prosecution or punishment
the perpetrators never admit to them in
large part because they refuse to allow
a criminal act to define them
men who commit murder in war are as
unlikely to consider themselves
murderers as the rest of us might deem
ourselves in veteran liars for the
little falsehood we told last wednesday
they cannot imagine how their own
existence could boil down to that single
instant when in the flash of a pistol or
the glint of a blade they put an end to
somebody else's existence
this was especially true of citizen
soldiers who win their terror horror
bigotry and rage committed atrocities
afterward they might return to what they
had been before they were pulled into
the sanguinary current of the war
farmers most of them church goers
citizens family men but with this
difference an inadmissible knowledge of
themselves in extremis
working from mountains of primary
material much of it untapped until now i
sought to understand the former slaves
who fought at fort pillow as individuals
because individuals are a good deal
harder to dismiss or ignore than some
generalized and mischaracterized mass
and i tried with equal energy to
understand the terrible hardships
betrayals and lethal fatalism of the men
who slaughtered them because they too
were hostage to the peculiar institution
and its beneficiaries
it has always been curious to me that
people who take pride in their ancestors
virtues refuse to take shame in their
vices
myths have their place in our
imaginations but in this vital region of
our history we should never allow them
to obstruct our search for the ever
evolving truth
i've come away from my research
convinced that until i understand what
slavery has done to us as a people to
northerner as well as southerner to
white as well as black i can never
understand this country at all
the history of african americans holds
the key to american history
and all it asks of the rest of us is to
turn it in the lock
not in order to let ourselves off the
hook but in an attitude of humility of
respect for those who still feel the
pain that it has inflicted over the
centuries
before we
because if we do not dare to pursue the
objective truth of that history we
cannot begin to untangle the knot of
guilt and shame and heartbreak that has
prevented us all from realizing our best
hopes for this country that we love
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you andy
um just to start off the questioning and
again for those in the audience any
questions you have because of book tv
being here if you can ask them in the
microphone on the left
um but andy just uh to sort of help us
out how is it that you
decided to zero in on fort pillow
uh versus all of the other battles that
are out there that seem to have the same
level of obscurity
well
uh
i i i have some connections to tennessee
in that my uh mother-in-law is a henry
county or what is she
died in 1998.
she's a great lady she was the a
farmer's daughter from buckhannon uh
tennessee from henry county
and
uh and i i have been to tennessee many
many times in the course of researching
a number of different projects i
mentioned it at the outset
that i had tried to write a book about
slavery and ended up having to abandon
it
i handed in probably 20 chapters
and my very good editor looked at it and
just said this is just a harangue nobody
is going to want to want to read this
and
the story was about a man from nashville
i had started out by doing some research
for a novel about the civil war that i
have yet to write and may never get to
um and the first day of my research i
wanted to find out something about
slavery in tennessee where much of the
novel was going to be located
and i found a collection of interviews
with a
fisk uh social scientist named uh
ophelia settle egypt one of the great
names i've ever encountered
uh and one of those interviews they were
all uh conducted anonymously and one of
those interviews uh was with a man who
sort of off-handedly
casually said that he
that his father was a cousin of abraham
lincoln and his father was his master
and in my innocence uh i was
astonished by this the notion that that
among the slaves that lincoln may have
emancipated was uh one of his own uh uh
relations
and i dropped my novel and decided that
i would use this man as sort of my
window into into into slavery he was
born in kentucky his father was indeed
lincoln's cousin though not a blood
relative
uh his um
uh he was uh given by his father his
master to uh his his own half brother
who took him up to missouri uh sold him
he said i was like joseph my own brother
sold me into slavery
he was sold bought and sold on a number
of coffels another number of slave
trading rounds finally ended up just uh
in nolansville just south of here
uh the property of a slave dealer named
ben harris
and during the war ran away to nashville
where he spent the rest of his life he
became a tin smith taught at central
tennessee college
and uh became a minister in the um uh af
the the amae
and
i i found that i i've sort of begun to
sort of
uh set roots in in this this area i
spent a lot of time uh in nolensville
and in nashville uh that's how i
encountered the story of the fiscal
jubilee singers
and i i am always fascinated by as i
said by massacres
uh and i'm always fascinated when there
are such diametrically opposed uh
accounts of what happened
uh and so it's like a moth to the flame
i was i was drawn to this most uh
controversial of of battles
any more any other questions
i
appreciate your um
you're delving into this history of
forest
you've no doubt seen his uh statue out
here on
on interstate 65 and uh you've no doubt
gone by the
sign for the state park named for him
uh off highway 40 out this way and
it's been embarrassing to me that
that forest has been
so uh held up for praise
by so many
tennesseans
and i think probably most of them um
don't know
very much at all about fort pillow i
never
heard of fort pillow until just a few
years ago
being from west tennessee myself i'm
particularly interested in
the white
union troops
who
fought there
and
if you could if you could tell us some
more about them
and
and also about
where we can find out more
about them in this area
it would just delight me to find that
some of my forebears had been
among those union troops who fought for
the union
well i um
i i devote a a couple of chapters to the
um
to what was called bradford's battalion
uh it was uh known as the 13th it was
officially the 14th uh tennessee cavalry
um at the time there was
terrible guerrilla warfare going on in
west tennessee as you must be aware
and um uh forest was especially incensed
by a man named fielding hearst who
commanded the sixth tennessee cavalry
and hearst was
an extortionist uh he has men committed
atrocities
um i think most of forrest's accusations
about fielding is
hurst and his men were probably
well-founded although there is a great
deal of question about what was uh
committed by guerrillas and what was
committed by regular army
um
but in i think in forrest when forest
was defending himself and accusing the
fort pillow garrison of atrocities he
was melding the 6th and the 13th
together
the 13th
consisted in part of men who had
given up the confederate cause
after they were
surrendered by the generals at fort
donelson
they were taken to prison in illinois
and they signed a
sort of release at parole
pledging not to fight for the
confederacy if they were allowed to
return home
they returned home some of them uh i
no bout didn't no doubt didn't have much
of a stomach for the cause in the first
place some of them though were went home
to protect their wives and children from
from guerrillas of both sides i mean if
nobody was safe it was a scoundrel time
um
uh and a a number of the men who served
in the 13th were also men who had
abandoned the sixth
uh be out of disgust with the atrocities
committed by fielding her standards and
his men
um
every time the
the two sides the uh every time the the
rebels collided with southern unionists
they were always struck by how similar
they were uh to themselves
uh when the seventh uh for instance uh
bluffed their way to victory at union
city they they the the men
encountered each other and and and uh
exchanged confidences and and all and
exclaimed by these men are just like us
and i think we we forget that there was
a kind of middle ground in this war
of men whose allegiances were shaky not
out of a lack of any kind of moral
conviction but the circumstances
prohibited them
from from making the kind of choice that
we might ask of them in retrospect
some of the men who fought at fort
pillow were exceedingly brave some of
the 13th some of them
agreed but it had the highest level of
desertion
much higher than the black troops
probably in part because black troops
had nowhere to desert two
uh but just on the evening of the battle
um
about 11 of them uh deserted uh it had
also been infiltrated by some of forest
spies there are a couple of them who
apparently had joined up in order to spy
on the garrison and then fled the night
or two two nights before and informed on
the garrison so it's a very very mixed
bag uh so i i
i don't know what i wish for you in
terms of uh in terms of finding out
whether an ancestor served uh in the
13th or not
because it was as i say it was such a
muddle in those times especially with
union occupation which occupations are
always ugly and this one was was was no
exception
yeah yes sir sir you you mentioned that
there are lots of primary sources that
you use for this
could you comment about why it seems to
be that as you mentioned some people
celebrate the virtues but we are not
willing to look at the shame why is it
that
the general has
had such a
such conflicting views
about him and that have lasted so long
thank you um
he was a um
he was a heroic figure on the face of
him he was six feet tall he stood in his
saddle so he looked even taller on uh he
was an unbelievable horseman
uh even a swordsman he he killed an
enormous number of men with his own
hands um
he was sort of the the bull ideal of the
cavalier except that he was a backwoods
uh sort of a backwoods man not the kind
of virginia bred gentleman that the
cavalier usually gets
ascribed to
um and i think people
um
impose on him uh a
uh an image that they want to believe
about about the warrior um
great warriors don't always make great
civilians uh you find over and over
again takes different very different
very different qualities
some of the things lessons he learned as
a slave trader served him very well in
the war
uh he had
he would run these couples of slaves
throughout the south
running all the way from texas i think
through mississippi in tennessee
kentucky
which meant that he had to learn how to
take care of large numbers of men
and
keep them fit for some future
dispensation in slavery's case for sale
in in wars case for for battle
i think the other pro
piece of it is that um this was a
theater of war that was short on heroes
especially that far west along the
mississippi
uh on the union side i suppose the
closest i would come to any kind of
counterpart well maybe abel straight but
but i think it's more likely ben
grierson who who led a great raid into
mississippi very audacious raid but even
he sort of fell apart at the seams
toward the end of the war
um
and forrest was a great uh had great
braggadocio uh he was a very good pr man
for himself uh he exaggerated his
victories he deprecated his setbacks
and and i think people were eager to put
slavery
aside as part of the myth of the lost
cause was to was to deprecate slavery as
a cause of the war and so it was
necessary to cut him away from that from
that from his own history in order to
build him up as as this iconic figure
i'm aware of the of the statue in um
here at i think it may well be the
ugliest statue to a civil war general of
any in the country and that's saying
something
uh
uh i i just came from memphis and in
memphis they have a uh they're having
quite a controversy over um a statue to
uh forest
uh and uh his remains were removed in
1910 from uh his resting place in
elmwood cemetery which is for the civil
war dead
to um to this municipal park
and they asked me what should we do
about this there are those who say it
should be removed and remains returned
to
the gravesite and there are those who
say that that would be rewriting history
and my view is that rewriting history is
what this country's always been about
and that the people who really rewrote
this the history were the people who
moved his remains his wish and his will
was to be buried with his men
and it was subscribers in 1910 who i
think had more uh
were more interested in
memorializing or monumentalizing jim
crow than they had in forests
in forest service uh who moved uh he
the general and his wife's remains to
this park
and that if they could just declare a
moratorium
uh if the african-american community
would back off for a couple of days and
give give forrest's admirers such as
they are time to move that statue and
move his remains
that this that he could cease to be
a thorn in the wound of racial division
in memphis
as i mentioned toward the end of his
life he was approaching a measure of
contrition
for his role uh in in in
slavery
and it seems to me that by removing him
from that park uh it would it would be
fit uh his own wishes toward the end of
his life
any other questions the other questions
yes sir
the word massacre
now in your hometown there was a real
massacre right
saint valentine's day massacre
in chicago yes yes sir
they were all killed right right no one
escaped right no prisoners right would
you give us your definition of massacre
well i'll give you the the the uh uh
dictionary
definition of massacre is that that uh
is a disproportionate number of of
killed but i i don't want to play the
numbers game and i'll tell you why
uh there are people in fact there's a
gentleman named john simprick who lives
here in tennessee and who's going to be
publishing his book about about fort
pillow he is with great diligence tried
to sort out the numbers involved
um and there's huge controversy about
the numbers what i'm what i'm describing
as massacre uh
can't rely on numbers because there all
the records were destroyed for the
garrison there there were no uh there
there were no records except one that
forrest mentioned of that there were 750
men at uh fort pillow i believe a lot of
those men were either on detached duty
or they were um or they had deserted
so i don't think it was 750.
the the common accepted
number is about
650 men
um
uh but again how many men were lost just
floating down the river how many had
been recruited in addition to how many
uh had deserted i i in the end i decided
that though i have footnotes about the
numbers that the the real
the real question of massacre hinges on
the circumstances in which men were
killed
and those circumstances were toward the
end of the after the fort had been
overrun
uh after everyone
by almost every account had thrown down
all their weapons
there were men lined up and shot down in
cold blood
there were men killed after
after forest departed and this is one
reason why i say i do not always dispute
what the what forest and his staff say
about what happened because they weren't
there they they left the missourians
under black bob mcculloch to watch over
the fort after the battle was over
and those and and and that evening there
were there were more men killed and in
the morning there were men killed in in
the hospitals
now i
want to call that murder you want to
call that slaughter you want to call
that massacre i won't argue with you but
uh but this is what i'm saying about
it's being a muddle that there is a
there is a a a fair fight up to a point
uh and then it a mutation into something
else
and that's the thesis of this book
yes sir
uh what were forest words or actions
that uh
caused you to say that he was
approaching contrition
for his role in slavery toward his death
well um toward the end of his life maybe
i could find that in here
anticipating alabama governor george
wallace's
ambiguous change of heart over a century
later forest defied as he put it quote
the jeers and sneers of a few white
people unquote to attend an
african-american picnic in 1875
where he declared that he and his black
audience quote may differ in color but
not in sentiment black and white came
from quote the same soil breathe the
same air live in the same land he said
so why should we not be brothers and
sisters he promised to do all in my
power to elevate every man and depress
none and declared himself with you in
heart and in hand
he was apparently sincere at least to
the extent that he had come to think of
blacks as fellow southerners if of a
decidedly inferior sort who could help
their former masters cast out white
radicals as he called them i shall not
shoot any negroes so long as i can see a
white radical to shoot he once declared
threatening that if all-out war returned
to memphis not one of them would get out
of this town alive
black and white were
becoming quote as one people having a
common interest forest assured some
yankee investors he hoped to interest in
yet another railroad scheme
he called on blacks to quote stand by
the men who raised you who nursed you
when you were sick and who took care of
you when you were little children
unquote if they stood by their former
masters forest promised quote we will
always stand by you and do as much for
you as any white man can do for you
unquote so it's not these are not words
necessarily saying i'm terribly sorry
for having uh made all that money uh as
a as a slave trader uh but he was
approaching
in the terms of the day a fairly radical
notion
of of inclusion uh for african-americans
especially considering his background
sir yes sir use the microphone please
yeah
the statistics and um numbers available
for the military deaths during the war
pretty
pretty well documented
um what about civilian deaths um were
they more or less than um
military deaths was there was there like
the taiping rebellion in china was like
millions of people killed was it
hundreds of thousands or thousands or
was there a lot of civilian casualties
during the war during the war the entire
war or fort port pillow the entire war
the entire war
i couldn't answer that i'm i'm not sure
i don't think it was terribly extensive
uh compared to uh 20th century war
warfare um
it was um
yeah i just can't answer that question
it's a good question i just don't have
the answer to it i'm sorry
uh at fort pillow uh there's some
evidence that there were some uh there
were certainly civilians fighting on the
union side who who were killed
um there were um also um some black
servants uh who were killed there's some
evidence that
that two women were at least one was
shot and one was
was killed but it's still a little the
evidence of that is a little bit shaky
uh one of the uh ways in which this
story got so muddled um is it it's a
little like uncle tom's cabin and the
effect it had on the debate over slavery
um
there were exaggerations about
the battle
that were published by the northern
press soon afterwards
and
one was by an abolitionist writer um who
gave this melodramatic story about a a
a woman who comes out onto the
battlefield to find her her black
husband wounded uh and uh the the
confederates tell her to flee and she
refuses and they shoot her down
and it and it just has all the earmarks
of propaganda it just doesn't doesn't
add up and
none of the details that the the writer
gives are
add up either and i found out later that
the author of it i'm afraid i found out
after i wrote the book that the author
of it himself has
just a famous liar about
as as he pursued his cause as a lot of
people who think they're working in a
just cause can can turn out to be um
so yes there were there were civilians
killed at fort pillow not by not a large
number maybe
i i i would estimate
a couple of dozen perhaps were
killed there yes sir
sir i don't have any question i just
want to make a statement
i hope that you have considered the fact
that
forest was not liked
by a lot of southern generals because of
his success
and no military training
he was also hated by many prominent
generals of the north
and so all of these things together may
make for a different picture
my grandfather happened to
ride
with
general forrest
can i ask what regiment he was in
he was a scout
for the first three years he went in
when he was 15 years old
and
he was a scout until
he became 18
when he was placed in the 51st alabama
partisan rangers
he
i don't think was at fort pila
but he was with
general forest when
forest chased
straight across alabama and tennessee
and to georgia
and being the shrewd man that he was
he
made a ploy
that caused straight to surrender some
twelve thousand men to his seven
thousand right the only thing i say is
this
remember that a lot of us
who had people who fought in that war my
grandmother my grandfather on my
mother's side was with the 18th alabama
infantry
and
it was a fact that
a lot of
people who had slaves
fought it's also a fact that neither one
of my families had slaves
and they fought because
the northern troops invaded the south
and they were protecting their families
and their homes at least that's what
they thought
so i ask you to
be kind to forests
in your evaluations when you seeked
out the fact that many of them hated him
he
faced
general braxton bragg
after the battle in chickamauga georgia
and
told him that
he would never serve under him again
and that if he ever spoke to him again
he would do so at the peril of his life
right
simply because he would not
let them go on
and
capture the remnants of the federal
troops at that time
he was hated so bad by
general sherman
that he said
that we could never have peace even
after the southerners had given up until
he was able to execute
forest
so
remember this when you talk about him
that all of the people that you're
talking about in that time
uh hated him
and so the picture that he paints
is not the picture of a man who was with
him
be kind i i appreciate your comments
very much um
i i want to uh i want to emphasize that
i did not appro approach these
conclusions eagerly uh because i too
have descended or i have
my wife has ancestors who did fight with
uh pillow i mean with forest at uh fort
pillow uh families uh from henry county
and um i'll tell you one story about how
i feel as though
we are sort of all of us uh tied up in
the same bunch here on this uh my
my uh when i first started uh studying
uh slavery i got interested in my own
family background about slavery
and uh in my in my wife's family my my
father-in-law was a hartford blue blood
and my mother-in-law as i said was a
farmer's daughter from from henry county
uh she some of her forebears uh served
under forest in in the escort and in the
uh 22nd and they're uh they were at fort
pillow and you're quite right your your
ancestor was not fighting at fort pillow
if he was in the 51st alabama
um
the joke in the family always was that
this northern abolitionist had married
this uh this slave holding secessionist
and it was just a kind of accepted that
there were these two cultures
well
it turns out that
the the up church family from henry
county never owned slaves
and the huntington family from hartford
were up to their necks in slave holding
and slave trading
in new london
uh and that the the abolition of slavery
that northerners were prescribing for
the south was much more uh precipitous
than the uh the the emancipation that
they themselves had imposed on
themselves uh i don't know if you know
this but new englanders didn't let go of
their slaves until each individual slave
had reached the point at which he was no
longer useful as a laborer about the
28th 28th birthday something like that
so
this is a this is not
a focus that i mean to bring to bear
solely on the south or on forest men
but but forests
involvement in the slave trade
isn't just a figment of of of yankee
imagination uh it was a substantial and
very formative part of his experience as
as a as a man and as a general
and um
i i admire his bravery and i admire his
tactics and his shrewdness
um and if i had been sherman i probably
would have shot myself because i was so
frustrated trying to pin him down
uh but um
his his his resume otherwise is not an
inspiration to me at any rate and uh
but i i do understand that secession and
slavery were not the same
were not the same causes for many men
they had no choice but to but to choose
uh to
fight andy thank you so much on behalf
of the southern festival of books we're
so glad you came to nashville and uh to
reiterate andy will be in the signing
colonnade immediately after this thank
you thank you very much
thank you very much
andrew ward is author of river run red
it's published by viking adult an
imprint of the penguin group for more
information visit penguin.com